[Music]
are there any rituals that you guys do
before the show it's your 200th show
tomorrow lots of chickens
lots of no rituals icing is the physics
thing yeah yeah and all the sugars like
as actors do you knew you know we all
have always little scene yeah well
sometimes yell in my underwear in my
room yes did not sometimes every every
time primal primal I wanted to try to
get loose so you know I take off all my
clothes and then I kind of walk around I
lunge into it and I yell I you know and
I do pond to the ground I can tell you
how does this help you I'll say yes yeah
we want to see it yeah so I you know I
wait you didn't take your clothes off
yeah yeah that's the best part right let
me get my gray Chester yeah no I go well
I you know you want almost their shoes
they're made of caramel yeah
[Applause]
oh you know what spins sometimes you put
caramel on apples yeah
Einstein so this is really the kind of
like I try to get the business to touch
the floor you know so and then I'll just
I'll like yell and try to get emotional
okay you know can we see some of that
well I'll just kind of go like with you
what would the scenes require you to do
this I mean it's most disturbing is he
insisted his dressing room door be open
well yeah naked
everyone all right guys let's get it up
in the second It's Showtime let's see I
want some yelling what's up some yellow
just kind of go like oh I'll just kind
of like this
because when I when I was in when I was
in acting school they said like oh you
keep your emotions in your hips yeah
yeah you're in your please keep them in
your X hey thanks for watching be sure
to click subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography